t
bien les voir dans les
plateformes électorales
des différents partis fédéraux.
Jacaudrey Charbonneau.
♪ ♪
GENEVIÈVE GAGNON, v.p. de Gagnon
La grande Quincaillerie
- La fameuse pénurie de main-
d'oeuvre dont tout le monde
parle, c'est notre plus grand
enjeu. Je dirais qu'à travers
nos 100 succursales, il nous
manque environ une cinquantaine
d'employés.
- On manque de chauffeurs
notamment. On manque également
de mécaniciens de véhicules
lourds, mais on manque également
de trieurs.
KARL BLACKBURN, président
Conseil du patronat du Québec
- Il y a des conséquence
catastrophiques au niveau de
l'économie et ça devrait être
l'enjeu numéro un des partis
fédéraux.
- On en a pour 10 ans. Ça fait
que si on ne veut pas que ce
soit catastrophique, il faut
s'orgasnier.
- Tout le monde en parle parce
qu'elle touche tout le monde.
Partout. La pénurie de personnel
est devenue l'ennemi numéro un
des entrepreneurs, surtout
depuis la pandémie.
- C'est du jamais vu manquer
autant d'employés et ce qui a
fait aussi qu'on a dû diminuer
nos heures d'ouverture.
On n'est presque plus ouvert
les soirs et on s'est positionné
comme étant un commerce
fermé les dimanches.
- Genevieve Gagnon possède
5 quicailleries dans différentes
régions du Québec en plus
d'une entreprise de fabrication
de matériaux de construction.
Comme beaucoup d'employeurs,
elle juge que la PCU, devenue
PCRE, est un frein à l'emploi.
- Nous, ça a un impact direct.
Ils envoient leurs CV parce
qu'ils doivent envoyer leur CV,
on n'a pas de retour d'appels.
On a des retours d'appels.
On embauche, ils se présentent
pas à leur première journée
de travail. C'est très, très,
très difficile.
- C'est un problème.
- Un avis partagé par le Conseil
du patronat.
- Actuellement, au Québec,
plus de 128 000 personnes
sont encore sur le programme de
la PCRE. Au Canada, c'est plus
de 845 000 personnes qui sont
encore sur le programme
de la PCRE. C'est inconcevable
dans un contexte de relance
économique.
- C'est vrai, surtout pour
les emplois moins bien
rémunérés, mais c'est loin
d'être la seule explication
à la pénurie de personnel.
MIA HOMSY, pdg, Institut
du Québec
- Les entreprises qui pensent
que ça va finir quand on va
couper la PCU, ils se trompent
parce qu'il y a plus
de personnes dans plusieurs
régions qui prennent
leur retraite que de jeunes qui
rentrent sur le marché
du travail.
- Les pressions pour augmenter
les salaires et améliorer
les conditions de travail
seront donc très fortes dans
les 10 prochaines années.
Les employeurs devront
s'adapter.
- Il faut complètement changer
notre approche avec
la dynamique d'emploi.
Des fois, il faut prendre
la personne à l'interne puis
juste lui offrir la formation
sur les heures de travail,
payée. C'est ce genre
de nouvelle réalité-là
vers laquelle on n'aura pas
le choix de migrer.
- Miser sur la formation
en milieu de travail, c'est
le genre de programme d'aide que
les partis fédéraux pourraient
offrir aux entreprises en pleine
campagne électorale.
- Il y a plein de petites
actions qui pourraient être
prises qui nous aideraient,
nous, les entrepreneurs.
- Des petites actions comme
favoriser la rétention
et l'embauche des personnes
âgées sur le marché du travail.
Autre solution : l'immigration.
- On va essayer de recruter
à l'étranger, notamment, ça,
c'est quelque chose sur lequel
on travaille très, très fort.
- Une demande qui revient
d'un secteur à l'autre.
Ricova est à la recherche
de camioneurs et d'éboueurs.
ALEXANDRE LAMPRON, conseiller
communication Ricova
- On a des contrats qu'il faut
respecter avec les municipalités
essentiellement et ça bouscule
un peu ces contrats-là, le fait
qu'on manque de personnel.
- Il faut aussi favoriser
les femmes sur le marché
du travail.
- Une forte proportion de notre
personnel, ce sont des femmes.
Si on veut engager la relève,
les jeunes femmes, elles ont
pas de places en garderie
ou des places qui ne peuvent pas
se permettre de payer
les montants qui sont demandés.
- Bref, tout pour accompagner
les entreprises à investir pour
faire face à cette réalité,
celle d'après la pandémie.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.